[Musica]
ho letto questo articolo scientifico
in cui si parlava di un algoritmo
che è in sperimentazione degli stati
uniti per il riconoscimento automatico
dei sintomi dell'autismo
molto prima che lo possano
riconoscere i medici tramite l'analisi
facciale e questa è sembrata una grande
notizia
dopo di che però facendo per la
sperimentazione si è visto che dato che
l'algoritmo impara dai dati che a
disposizione e questi dati sono
soprattutto di bambini
caucasici
più una bambina ispanica e quindi li na
verrebbe sputa automaticamente
di cura il supporto e questo dire
sia al contempo
questi come vedete
la stessa tecnologia
può portare grandi avanzamenti ma anche
presentare i rischi
questo perché la tecnologia peraltro è
noto è neutra è buona o cattiva
dipende come viene utilizzata quello che
però è fuor di dubbio è che una cosa
come questa
fino a pochissimi anni fa non era
neanche immaginabile
e infatti
stiamo vivendo un grande cambiato quello
che ci porta a una società digitale non
è una trasformazione una rivoluzione sta
cambiando e non sarà più lo stesso in
poi si sa
ventata la stam
cari contemporanee
pensare
esposte
temporo per qualche morto copia
o quando è stato inventato il motore a
scoppio è possibile è stato pensato che
ci sarebbero state meno carrozze in meno
cocchieri occupati ed è invece non è
andata così per queste invenzioni hanno
cambiato la società ha cambiato il mondo
infatti noi siamo di fronte a un nuovo
mondo che si sta costruendo che stiamo
costruendo
dovremmo costruire bene perché è un
mondo che ci dà grandi possibilità ma
anche grandi rischi
allora la prima cosa è non creare
disparità
quindi in modo che tutte e tutti possano
essere cittadini di questo mondo dare a
tutte e tutti
le conoscenze di base e pare possibile
la nuova segregazione appunto la nuova
disparità che è rappresentata quello che
viene chiamato digital divided
ovviamente questo nuovo mondo
porterà nuovi lavori e altri lavori
diventeranno obsoleti esattamente come i
cocchieri delle carrozze oppure gli
stessi cavalli
cosa me personalmente un po dispiace
perché io sono grande appassionata di
cavalli ed equitazione
ma parallelamente ce ne saranno di nuovi
molti
e ci saranno necessità sempre di più di
competenze
competenze multidisciplinari e vero ma
competenze digitali
perché il digitale fa ibridando tutti i
vari settori
non si è parlato molto in questo periodo
di pandemia di come
l'informatica
abbia
inciso profondamente
nella possibilità di avere un vaccino e
vedendo come gli algoritmi con analisi
dati come tutto quello che c'è dietro la
ricerca medica sia stato essenziale è
stato così non se ne parla molto ma è
stato così le competenze digitali
l'informatica possono davvero dare nuovi
strumenti per affrontare problemi vecchi
e nuovi sempre più complessi
e chiaramente ne abbiamo sentito parlare
anche oggi
il digitale va insieme alla
sostenibilità
per creare un mondo che non che sia
migliore migliore in cui ci sia del
valore socio ecologico come una priorità
e che sia più equo più inclusivo diverso
solidale e sostenibile
tutto questo è un concetto su cui
presumo siamo tutti d'accordo ma questo
nuovo mondo dobbiamo creare noi avendo
consapevolezza e sapendo gestire i
rischi che comunque esistono
insieme alle innovazioni
su questa slide c'è un lungo elenco di
rischi di cui non parlerò voglio
solamente trattare il primo cioè
l'amplificazione dei pregiudizi e delle
disuguaglianze
vogliamo un mondo nuovo
inclusivo e senza disuguaglianze
ma quello che stiamo costruendo è
davvero un mondo nuovo
vediamo un piccolo esempio
questo piccolo esempio si riferisce ad
amazon che penso tutti conosciamo
allora la forza lavoro di amazon è
composto al 60 per cento degli uomini e
il
trequarti circa delle posizioni apicali
sono coperte da uomini
a un certo punto è stato sperimentato un
nuovo algoritmo anche in questo caso per
selezionare
reclutare delle nuove figure
professionali anche per posizioni
apicali e chi l'ha costruito si è basato
sui dati che aveva a disposizione
cioè i dati che riguardavano il
personale presente in azienda
quindi curricula essenzialmente di
uomini
e questo algoritmo anche lui non è che è
buono cattivo impara da quello che a
disposizione per questo c'è il rischio
che amplifichi pregiudizi e
disuguaglianze che sono presenti nella
nostra società
e quindi ha scartato i curricula
femminili per che usavano un linguaggio
diverso
ora notoriamente
uomini e donne hanno sicuramente le
stesse capacità
ma
utilizzano per esempio un linguaggio
leggermente diversa questo caso il
linguaggio femminile è stato considerato
non idoneo
quindi diciamo se volevamo un
miglioramento nella composizione delle
posizioni apicali di amazon con
l'introduzione di
donne è quello che è successo è stato
esattamente il contrario perché sono
stati assunti uomini finché qualcuno se
n'è accorto che le cose stavano andando
peggio e quindi è stata abbandonata
l'algoritmo nonché per questo abbiano
assunto vieta
allora qual è uno dei problemi ed è uno
dei problemi è che questo mondo nuovo
dal punto di vista delle competenze
digitali cioè degli architetti che
stanno contribuendo sostanzialmente a
disegnarlo
è fatto solo da uomini
questi architetti sono per il 90 per
cento uomini
quasi tutti bianchi
ma non
diciamo vi parlerò del problema etnico
adesso è il problema di genere quello di
in discussione perché perché non ci sono
ragazze ce ne sono sempre meno ma non è
che non ci sono ragazze in posizioni
apicali
non ci sono ragazze non ci sono ragazze
nei nostri corsi di laurea pochissime
non ci sono ragazze nei corsi di laurea
negli stati uniti anzi sono in costante
carlo
erano arrivati a un certo punto degli
anni 90
al 28 per cento
tantissime nel 2014 al 18 per cento
adesso sono calate ancora un pochino
si sa se voi guardate
quel diagramma vedete che le ragazze
frequentano l'università molto si
laureano con profitto più dei maschi in
genere prendendo tutto il
l'insieme delle universitarie degli
universitari c'è solo uno di quei
segmenti in cui il colore è bassissimo
come vedete quello delle tecnologie
dell'informazione
dove le ragazze continuano a essere su
uno striminzito
10 13 per cento
allora io penso che nessuno né uomini né
donne voglia un mondo nuovo disegnato a
senso unico solamente da maschi bianchi
e quindi il punto e cercare di capire
come
far diventare
le ragazze partecipi di questo processo
perché non ci sono
beh
non ci sono soprattutto
per una lunga e assolutamente non
superata storia di stereotipi e
pregiudizi
e inutile cercare motivazioni
sofisticate
il problema è la
e quello che nelle scuole nelle famiglie
nella società ancora viene perpetuato lo
stereotipo e il pregiudizio della non
adeguatezza delle ragazze per in
generale le materie scientifiche in
particolare la matematica
dopodiché c'è un problema di narrativa
per cui l'informatica viene narrata per
esempio nei film
come un qualche cosa che viene fatta da
persone estranee
chiuse in stanze buie da sole senza una
vita sociale senza un fidanzato senza
niente se vuoi confrontate questa
narrativa con quelle delle dottoresse
potete pensare
facilmente perché i ragazzi e giovani
non sono particolarmente attratte
dall'informatica
dopodiché c'è tutta una diciamo
costruzione i pregiudizi ancora nella
scuola la tombola delle frasi e un libro
del 2020 usata nelle scuole elementari
nel 2020 dove la mamma cucina
i bambini giocano
e il papà lavora
difficile crederlo eppure del 2020
poi c'è un altro discorso da fare le
donne
nell'informatica appunto sono strane a
sociali
attuate in maniera
di nuovo stravagante oppure sono donne
eccezionali
per esempio hedy lamarr hedy lamarr le
potrà essere stata una fantastica
bellissima attrice la donna più bella
del mondo al suo tempo e una donna
assolutamente
controcorrente al di sopra dei
pregiudizi
era anche una ingegnera e ha contribuito
all'invenzione di un protocollo che
usata adesso nei sistemi wifi moderni
nessuno parla di una donna come di
nakata b che è quella ragazza che
che li in foto di nakata b professoressa
all'emmeti
inventrice anche lei di un nuovo
algoritmo per il wireless
ragazza come potete vedere dalla foto
normalissima però chiaramente non fa
notizia non è perché dobbiamo parlare di
nakata b non è una donna eccezionale si
parla solo di donne eccezionali in certi
settori
e le ragazze non si sentono per lo più
eccezionali e questo è un altro problema
perché per prima cosa
le ragazze dovrebbero
essere curiose
e intraprendere un percorso
un percorso
diciamo di conoscenza e di ricerca di sé
e delle proprie capacità
come fa alice
alice io penso che dovrebbe essere
insegnata in tutte le scuole elementari
del mondo e sicuramente in italia non il
libro ii della con la mamma che cucina o
spazi
perché alice riesce
superando pregiudizi
e
luoghi comuni
convenzioni e anche dubbi tanti dubbi
sulle proprie capacità
riesce a sconfiggere il ciciarampa
ea prendere il tè con il cappellaio
matto
che peraltro nel film diciamo valeva
veramente la pena di renderci
bene
se noi vogliamo un mondo in cui un mondo
diverso un mondo migliore un mondo che
faccia tutto che unisca tutti questi
valori
narrati
equo solidale diverso per prima cosa
dobbiamo proprio considerare tutti gli
uomini e donne il valore della diversità
e non far costruire questo mondo non
permettere che sia costruita solamente
da uomini bianchi
perché avrà un sacco di problemi ci
saranno un sacco di occasioni perse
e poi ragioniamo anche in chiusura
su due considerazioni pratiche
innanzitutto con le competenze digitali
si trova lavoro in un attimo e questo è
un messaggio a ragazze e ragazzi
anzi il vostro problema
potrebbe essere quello di ricevere
troppe offerte di lavoro e trovarle un
po
noiose un po
petulanti
e dato che ci sono migliaia e migliaia
di posti di lavoro scoperti
se le ragazze si convincessero che
l'informatica è un settore creativo
fantastico che può davvero cambiare le
cose beh si stima che l'economia
in europa per esempio avrebbe una
crescita del pil tra il 2 e il 3 per
cento nei prossimi dieci anni
quindi ne guadagneremmo tutti
grazie
[Applauso]